hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round one of the
great HS classic here we have a game
between Vishwanathan Anand and the holy
fun now I did the promised you some
photos from round one as in the first
video I didn't really have any so let's
just dive right into them here is a
photo of Carson shaking her honest and
Carson just arrived for the match here
we have a nice a nice close-up of Magnus
Carlsen or from the beginning of the
game here we have also a very nice
close-up of Fabiano Caruana here we have
this is the moment who were constantly
that rook to h2 check the final check
before that before they agreed to a draw
in the yesterday's game and here we have
also a very nice photo of course and end
which won a tournament from the
beginning of the tournament it couldn't
really really make it fullscreen as its
kind of a kind of a really wide photo
and here from this game Anand versus Hui
found here we have a very nice close-up
of Viswanathan Anand and also a very
nice close-up of holy fun so I do expect
to have a lot of a lot of great photos
for every round and this is all courtesy
of the grand KHS classic video
production team I will introduce them in
another video as I will be making more
videos but yeah it's very interesting
last time Anand and who even played was
in the tata steel chess tournament in
january and i did prepare here these
were the these are the final standings
of the tata steel masters Anand won his
game against - and as you can see how he
found a one only two and a half points
out of 13 so there wasn't really a great
tournament for her only 5 draws all the
other games were lost so she she was
last in this tournament and everyone
said you know only two and a half points
out of 13 that's like you know she
should give up on chess you know the
people were saying yeah women can play
chess there's really nothing what was
she thinking about coming there but then
again here are the final standings of
the 2018 candidates tournament where you
have a
Grandmaster like Levon Aronian and he
won only four and a half points out of
14 games so not really not really it's
hardly a better score than two and a
half points
Evon made out of 13 games so no one was
really saying to Ariane maybe maybe you
should give up on chess altogether
something just something I wanted to
mention so I'm very interested to see
what progress even even made and how did
the Tata Tata Steel masters experience
influence her in her work in growth so
already in round one having the black
pieces against Vishwanathan Anand
definitely definitely an exciting
matchup so let's see how it went and I
I'm not gonna spoil anything but it's
already an interesting game from the
very first moves so nice to have three
by Anand
we have Knight this Knight to f6 and c4
so the English opening and before I
forget as I know I'm gonna forget it
till the end of the video I do want to
thank everyone for asking so many
questions
I'm sure the Grand Cay team will have a
lot of questions to choose from and I
hope they they managed to ask most of
them there were a lot of interesting
questions I even have one here by unab
Mahajan a question for Fabiano Caruana
does he prefer the style of Mikhail
Botvinnik or Michael Tao now of course
really enjoyed this question as I I do
hope it was influenced by my towel
versus bottom Enix series so you know
you guys are really getting the hang of
of this whole chess idea so yeah you
will be able to watch watch their
official stream I will also put a link
in the description below where you can
check that out and all of these photos
are from a beautiful trailer beta made
by the cranky chess classic team so the
first thing you'll see in the
description below is a link to that
trailer they will be making a trailer
after every round so do check it out I
highly recommend it as you know even if
you don't enjoy chess the video is is so
great you know the quality of the video
is amazing so do check it out ok so
getting back to the game we have e 6
Knight to c3 and now d5 III Bishop to d6
b3 now prepare
to develop the bishop to be to castles
Bishop to b2 and c5 now and here already
under goes for a very interesting
variation g4 so what's the idea
well he does have a this Bishop on b2
which could become very strong eyeing
that x-raying that g7 pawn and if if I
were to capture this it's not it's not a
mistake
capturing this pawn but after rook to g1
forcing that nice to move and then
you're gonna have problems there's a
bishop on b2 rockin g1 so probably d4
and after rook captures pawn captures
Knight Bishop captures now your g7 point
is hanging there and it's it's not
another neezy position if you're not
prepared for this would black probably
best would be e5 but opening up and
discovered attacked with rook but here
white can actually decide to give up the
exchange and then after black goes f6 93
simply captures captures and white white
can even after after castling bring
bring the rook all the way to g1 and it
could be could be a dangerous position
for black so obviously if I don't offer
this he does have some ideas I mean not
some he probably has all of the ideas
how to play this so if an isn't
interested in capturing the spawn
instead she decides to go for a pawn
sacrifice of her own she plays d4 he
captures on d4 pawn captures on d4 and
now Knight captures and d4 so
sacrificing a pawn and now e5 Knight to
f5 Bishop captures G captures and now
Knight to c6 so not only did she give up
a pawn but she also gave on the open G
file why did she do it well you'll just
have to see here placed Bishop to g2 now
I haven't seen the interview with Anand
or I don't even know if there was one
but Bishop to g2
I don't know if it's if this is an
imprecision Queen to f3 would be better
here because it it would directly
prevent offense idea but maybe Anand was
going for what you'll see in the game
straight from the start so Bishop to g2
by Anand and now Knight the b4 and this
is why Queen to f3 might have been
better first and only then develop the
bishop
now night before could have been met by
simply castling here it's it's
impossible to Castle you could Castle
kingside
but then after night to d3 this night is
simply a monster you're not gonna get
rid of it from d3 the bishop is attacked
on b2 once you defend it you can even go
for and all hell will break loose now
this bishop now targets the HT to pawn
this night when it moves the queen is
coming to h4 this would be an extremely
dangerous position and the if and is a
great attacker so this this would be
very difficult to play for Anand so
after night the before on and now
decides to make a counter blow he plays
Queen to e2 now on stun sacrifices the
exchange so night to see to this comes
with Chuck King to d1 attacking the
knight Knight captures rockin a1 and
Bishop captures so okay on the leaf and
sacrifice the pawn but now an unsecured
feisty exchange so you know everyone
everyone wants to play for the win and
play they play interesting chess Queen
to d7 going for the f5 pawn and now
Knight to e4 with the idea that of
course if you capture the pawn then
white will capture the bishop on on d6
but it doesn't matter even captured on
f5 and captured the bishop and here even
played Queen to be two and this was
checkmate
now of course this didn't happen I just
wanted you had to see why you can
capture this after Queen captures an f5
of course you can't grab the bishop so
Knight captures on f6 with Czech Queen
captures on f6 and now Bishop captures
on b7 grabbing another pawn rook to d8
and now King to see two rook to e8 and
it's it's it's of no use to go something
like Bishop to b4 to pressure this d2
pawn white candle always put d3 and and
everything is fine so instead a rook to
e8 and now Bishop the c3 adding more
protection to the d2 pawn and not
allowing this bishop any Bishop to b4
ideas in the future Bishop to c5 with a
double attack on the f2 pawn here f3 and
now Bishop to d4
rook to e1 we have g6 queen to e4 King
to g7 improving the position and now
Bishop to d5 and although well Yifan
still is up the exchange her rooks
aren't really all that useful look at
Anand spawn chain here and the bishop on
top of the pawn chain it's it's
impenetrable
so those rooks are never gonna see any
action in this game Queen to b6 we have
before now f5 Queen to d3 and out Bishop
captures on see 3d captures on c3 to
improve to improve this pawn structure
and now the rook will also be able to
use the D file Queen 36 now comes a four
a five and now kink the b3 rook to b8 b5
now Queen - Queen to c5 and now h4 and
now on and we'll try to break up on the
Queen side we have rocked to the 8 h5
King to F King to f6 and now H captures
H captures on g6 and now Queen to e3 I
with the idea of exchange in Queens so
even though on this down the exchange
he doesn't mind exchanging Queens and
even goes for a queen captures only 3
it's a interesting idea might be for
something like rook to d5 to grab back
some of the points because your looks
really aren't doing all that much and
after pawn captures Queen captures with
check but after c4 and queen d6 with
some Queen before ideas Queen c3 and the
material is equal now but it's actually
Anand who has two two connected passed
pawns
so this would be winning for Anand so
after Queen to e3 Queen captures and now
rook captures and rook to d6 here we
have rook to e1 rope to c8 and rook to
h1 King to g7 and not allowing this rook
to come into the game King to see - and
now g g5 it's it wouldn't be really
useful to play something like rook to da
truck to HH to exchange looks as if you
exchange rooks then to fast
- connected passed pawns protected by
the bishop would be a very scary
position for
even probably even winning for Anand
rough 2d one now King to f6 King to d3
rope to b6 rope to h1 came back to g7
not allowing the rook to infiltrate rock
to g1 King back to f6 King to e3
rook to d6 rock the b1 rook to b6 King
to e2 so there's really no way for
either side to make progress and the
engine agrees the engine evaluates this
position as zero point zero zero so a
day to draw King to g6 King to have to
King to f6 rook to h1 and here King to
g7 and rook to e1 this might even be a
threefold repetition but either way they
agree to a draw this is move 48 so a
great start for a fun and a nice game by
both of them Anand already going
aggressive on move six with that g4 move
even declining yet playing upon
sacrifice of her own and then an
encounter in with a nice exchange
sacrifice so all in all an excellent
game and you know it it's really gonna
be nice that all the games if all the
games will be like this
and one other thing I'm really looking
forward to is seeing how our engines
experience influenced him in the
candidates and how will he play the
grand KHS plastic as he is the Branka
chess classic 2017 champion so basically
he came here to defend his title so
we'll see if indefinitely I mean not
definitely if and certainly did improve
after her score in the Tata Steel
masters I will show it one more time
here we have two and a half out of 13
but we'll see how she'll do in this
tournament so yeah I will do a couple of
more videos so in case I forgot
something I will probably I will
definitely mention it in some of my
other videos and like I said I highly
recommend you check out to the Greg HS
classic official video about round 1
it's a very short trailer but the I mean
the the quality of the of the video is
amazing so do check it out and I would
like to thank Nicola pallucci and
Tony more guitar for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check
through my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
probably would not a video from the gran
key chest classic thank you